foreign
[Music]
level data science success
it's making data science a success in a
large company that's what I want to talk
to you about who am I I've used our
for about six years
I come from an engineering background
in my professional role I lead a data
science analytics and software team in
the supply chain organization
the silver lining of the last two years
is I don't have to explain what supply
chain means to anybody from toilet paper
to semiconductor chips everybody
understand what supply chain means
Flex is a large Electronics
Manufacturing Company it's a Fortune 500
company it's located in 30 different
countries we manufacture Electronics
things in 30 different countries
outside of work my primary role is a dad
to two young kids
and Mom currently thinks I'm on vacation
in a fancy conference Resort
the session was themed working with
people is hard it is hard
I agree that it is not easy
but I'm here to try and convince you a
little bit
that it need not be this hard
so what does
data science success in an Enterprise
mean I'm going to give you one
definition that's my definition
where there is effort that leads to some
output and then there are decisions made
with that output and actions and outcome
for an organization on an or an
Enterprise
so we know what the effort the tools
that we use in the effort and the
outputs are we use R and python we
publish our outputs
now for the second part decisions are
generally made with other people in
meetings whether it be with higher ups
or your peers or with people who will
Who are the practitioners and users of
the output that we provide
and actions and outcomes typically mean
we make more sales we make more Revenue
the key performance indicators show
Improvement after implementing the
Analytics
my talk is going to be centered around
this the third and fourth phases of
making data science a success
and in most organizations data science
and analytics is a means to an end
it is success is measured by dollars and
metrics of what is important to the
business
so it's a means to an end in most cases
I say four
sets as very fundamental to
data science success in a corporation
it's the data set the tool set and the
skill set
is talked about a lot in this conference
we have different tools that we have we
improve our skills
in this talk I'm going to talk more on
the mindset within an organization of
how to take it from
development deployment by the first two
boxes that you saw implementation
actioning and outcome is the what the
mindset change that is acquired for the
last two processes
partnership this is a word that means a
lot and I emphasize this within the
organization there is a tendency to
treat data science and I.T organizations
as a service provider within an
organization
my
passionate recommendations do not settle
for this
ask for equal ask to be equal partners
and what that means
is
the data science team gets equal input
to key decisions that are made with the
analysis that they are get to offer
opinion they get to guide
the non-deters and the business people
to execute on the output
and in return the data science team
also owns the business outcome so we
take on an additional challenge of
owning business outcomes and not just
model deployment
so in terms of maturity of an
organization to utilize and Implement
data science
I think of these as two-dimensional one
is the analytics maturity or data
science maturity this could be ingesting
large amounts of data running complex
models the other important Vector is
decision maturity is the organization
how good is the data literacy of the
organization how good are they in
decision making with the uncertain
outputs that we have both of these
vectors will have to grow for data
science to be successful in an
organization and they have to go sign
grow
simultaneously and
both have to mature for it to be a
success
decision maturity is
a fancy term for saying have a decision
framework to utilize the output that is
given from Analytics
um
and for the data science team it is
important to understand
what are the key metrics that are
important for the practitioner of the
analytics or what's important for the
business
and we talk a lot about model metrics
model accuracy classification error
whatever the case might be
the model metrics only need to be the
current business process metric to be
implementable
um it's a two-horse race a model
accuracy does not need to be at 99 to be
implemented if the business process
metric is today at 70 you don't have to
beat the world record to beat the other
horse you just have to beat the other
horse and then
make decisions to implement
the data science side of things on the
business side of things
this is contradictory to
um
you know working nicely with people it's
important to pick some fights and you
have to fight for the right reasons
friction is a very necessary component
to moving forward
good friction is good
that removes hurdles and blockades that
sometimes come when different teams have
to work together to move things forward
I want to make an illustration or an
example of how do we go from model
output to decision making you see a
picture of Google Maps that takes us
from where we are today to Dallas
Airport
many of us will be making this trip in
the next 24 hours Google Maps tells me
it's going to take 45 minutes
I asked the question to Google Maps how
long is it going to take but that's not
the real question
when I have to make a decision with the
answer it's given me the decision making
breaks down into multiple tree type
decision making
do I want to take Uber or can I afford
to take public transportation do I have
time for coffee when you put this
decision-making framework on top of the
very complex analytics that's running
behind Google Maps that gives you a
framework to connect
data science to business type decision
making talk to your stakeholders to
understand what decisions do they really
want to make with the data output
going from a generic example I'll go to
a
supply chain and a specific example
within the supply chain organization we
have analytics that support
that provide output for what the price
of a part should be my organization and
Company by millions of Parts every year
so the current you can see the scale of
the pricing
when we provide some model outputs that
show lower than current price the person
who has to execute on it when they first
see it
they get some pressure they get some
pressure or fear that they have to go
meet the Target and the pressure of fear
is not
within that one person's scope but their
manager also sees this data so that's
where the pressure comes from so there
is an there is a very high chance that
giving analytics in an organization can
create some pressure or fear however
if the person were to achieve any lower
price for that part whether it meets
that regardless of whether it meets the
Target or not that's an opportunity so
you
it is very important to work within an
organization to change
people's perception of analytics from
feeling pressure or fear to creating
that opportunity and growth mindset
so we call it the pressure to
opportunity mindset change and it takes
time when you work with different teams
and humans tend to judge machines and
models very harshly I'll give two
scenarios with this exact case of
pricing apart
now let's take the case of the part was
a dollar and the model output was 90
cents
and the actual achievement after the
negotiation was 95 cents
in the in case one or scenario one with
the model
people tend to judge the model and say
the model has 50 data
in case number two or scenario two
without a machine or a model
and when a human went in with a low bid
as a starting point
and they started with 90 cents and got
up to 95 cents as the result
it was a good negotiating strategy so
humans tend to
judge machines and models in a very
harsh way we have a lot of empathy
towards other humans so
what we have learned in doing analytics
at scale within a large company is
be aware of being judged in a very harsh
way and prepare for that
so with people
this building relationship with
relationships with people up down and
sideways up the management change with
chain with your teams and your peers
the data science and analytics team to
be successful have to learn to
understand and talk the language of the
business teams
um when we say models and random forests
and regression
everybody does not understand those
terms it makes them a little closed and
feared
so we have to open up and learn to talk
their language to get how they can
execute and do their jobs better with
what we are giving them
in building a successful team takes time
manage lead and Coach are
three different things and all three
have to be done in a different way
and similarly as
we challenge the non-datas to speak our
language we have to challenge the data
science team in an organization
to speak the business teams language
some pitfalls that I've learned over
time
when management asks for
machine learning whenever they start a
question is let's see if AIML can help
you that's usually a rabbit hole
um can we find something interesting
from the data that's another big rabbit
hole
be aware of
scope creep in an organization have a
clear plan and a threshold for aborting
a project with your project stakeholders
so working with people need not be this
hard
working with people is a very necessary
component of Enterprise level data
success
so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]